hi everyone today i would like to talk
about
our ongoing work on leveraging synthesis
for code translation
from parallel programming to data
analytics we have seen the development
of various domain-specific languages and
frameworks
across different fields all of these
languages
pride themselves on different domain
specific optimization techniques
so to leverage them one only needs to
express
the computation using the programming
paradigms or dsls
that are exposed by such frameworks
and now the pace of these new frameworks
have been particularly
fast in deep learning as we see from
this condensed timeline on the slide
and the explosion of such dsls and
frameworks
pose new challenges for programmers who
must
now learn to master them in order to
make their applications run
efficiently so for the past few years
my group has been working on tools and
techniques
to help developers write code easily
without needing to worry about the
underlying programming paradigm
or framework so let me give you an
example
suppose we want to express a row-wise
mean
of a matrix in java so here's one simple
implementation
where we initialize an integer array
that stores the row-wise mean of every
row
and then we just go through every row
one after another
and then as as we traverse each row we
would also go through each of the
columns
and then finally sum everything up and
divide
to get the row wise mean as you can see
this is basically
a computation expressed using nested
loops
over arrays now let's say we want to
rewrite
this piece of computation but this time
using
a mapreduce mechanism
so here is the exact same computation
again but is now expressed
using a function as a functional program
over
rdds that are exposed by the spark
framework you might imagine one way of
doing this translation
is to write a compiler so we've all
taken a compiler class so this is
basically the basis
of syntax driven compilation
all we need to do is to express
different patterns so for example in
this case here's a pattern
that express that that says that if we
can recognize this particular
form of the loop then we can translate
it
into the equivalent map expression
expressed
using spark or map reduce
and in fact there has been previous work
in trying to solve this exact problem
so back in 2014 uh there's a paper
written
by a bunch of really smart uh
researchers
which basically tried to do this exact
same thing
so here is one of the rules that they
use
to recognize the initial code pattern
and then in order to perform this
translation for this
kind of obligatory program that counts
uh words right and a bunch of documents
in java
all that we need to do is to apply
a bunch of rules
and a few more rules and
finally after 22 rules afterwards we
finally get our shiny program
now written using mapreduce
so anyone in this syntax different
compilation business
will ask the question of why are there
so many rules
and note that in this case this is a
very simple program
that only does work counting in
sequential
in sequential java and that already
require us to
apply 22 different of these pattern
matching rules
and now please don't get me wrong here
so this is in fact
a pioneer piece of work that actually
shows us that it is indeed possible to
do such translation
from sequential java into mapreduce
but what i'm trying to get at here is
the fact that writing these rules
is just hard these rules are brittle
in the sense that we might will never
know whether we actually missed some
rules that would lead to an incomplete
translation
they are difficult to be correct to get
right right so
if any one of these translations turns
out to be wrong then it's really hard to
catch them
and they're also hard to maintain so
just imagine maintaining hundreds of
different rules to do these kind of
pattern matching translation
and the problem doesn't stop here so
today we might want to write a compiler
that translates from java to spark
tomorrow we might want to write another
compiler that translate from java to sql
or any other kind of domain specific
language that you can imagine
and the number of source languages also
keep increasing
we have java we have c python and some
legacy code everywhere
so this is basically an arms race to
build new compilers for every new dsl
that appears on the horizon
now let's try to take a step back and
look at the problem from a different
point of view
here is the same problem again our goal
here is try to translate from this java
program
into functional mapreduce so let's say
we are the designer of spark
we already have an intimate knowledge
about how the spark language works
instead of doing a direct translation
what if
we first design a high level
specification language
this language only has a few constructs
such as
map and reduce and that all the values
must be derived from a series of these
mappers
and reducers the language here doesn't
capture all the concrete syntax of the
target language here
so being spark but it already captures
most of the functionalities provided
i claim that we can now write easily a
syntax driven compiler
that translates from this high level
specification language
into the concrete syntax of spark or
mapreduce
now all we need to do is somehow we
express
the original computation that we have
using this high level specification
language
and we are done we call this process
inference because we are basically
trying to translate from
the source here to this high-level spec
language
and as a preview i can tell you that we
are not going to solve this problem
using syntax driven compilation
but before we actually discuss how we
solve this inference problem
let's first tackle the question of how
can we actually
check that these two programs here are
indeed
computing the same thing
so instead of viewing this blue code as
a program written in this high level
specification language
let's actually view this as a logical
statement
informal methods as i'm sure many of you
already know
this is basically a post condition it is
a logical
assertion that states what needs to be
true
if in this case the code fragment
actually terminates
now in order to prove that this post
condition is indeed valid
we also need something known as loop
invariance which many of you are already
familiar with
which just states what needs to be true
while the loop
is still executing now we already have
actually established a
formal mechanism to check if given
in if given an invariant in the post
condition
whether that whether they are indeed
valid or not
and these come in the form of something
known as verification conditions
for example we need to check that if we
have a loop invariant
then that loop invariant is already true
when we first enter the loop
we need to check that the loop invariant
is preserved across
multiple iterations of the loop and
finally
we need to check that if the loop
actually terminates then the loop
invariant implies
the post condition i'm not going to bore
you with the details in this case for
this simple program here
all that i'm trying to say is that if we
are given
these loop invariants and post
conditions then
there is actually a mechanical way to
check
whether these invariants and post
conditions are indeed true
and if they are true then in this case
our post condition
is basically the program that we have
been looking for
in this inference process
now of course the million dollar
question is how do we
come up with these post conditions and
invariants after all
all that i have told you so far is that
if we have
such invariant and post condition then
there is a way to check
this is exactly the place where program
synthesis comes into play
i'm sure many of you are already
familiar with program synthesis
but as a very simple introduction a
synthesizer
basically takes in two things as inputs
it takes in a description of the search
space
and then it also takes in a bunch of
constraints that describes what is
a valid solution and given these two
inputs
hopefully we can turn the crank and then
it will just come
up with expressions from the search
space that actually satisfies
the constraints that we provided and the
problem in our hands right now
what are these solution constraints and
what is the search space description
well the constraints are exactly the
verification conditions
that i alluded to earlier on the
previous slide
they are indeed the governing conditions
that
state what a solution needs to satisfy
in order for it to be a valid one
what about the search based description
how do we actually feed that in
into the synthesizer
well one way of doing it is to do a
simple code analysis
on the input source code that we are
trying to translate
for example using data flow analysis we
can figure out that
in this case there are two different
array variables that we are trying to
manipulate
and a simple structural analysis will
tell us that the
operators that are involved include
something like addition
and division given these two basic
ingredients
we can now start to write possible
invariance and both conditions
of the following forms so for instance
we might guess initially that the mean
variable corresponds to a single map
reduced
single map stage on the input matrix
or we can guess that is actually
consists of a two-stage
map followed by a reduction of the input
matrix
and then the form of the mapper and
reducer functions can be of various ways
as stated here
obviously we're not going to really
write out all these programs and
enumerate them one after another for the
synthesizer to choose
but instead we're going to encode
everything
as a grammar that i've expressed here on
the right hand side
so there we have both of the ingredients
that we need to
fit into the program synthesizer we have
the verification conditions
as the constraints that govern what a
valid solution should look like
and we have the expression grammar that
talks about what
is the space of programs that we are
trying to search over
and if we run through them over a
synthesizer
then hopefully the synthesizer will able
to come up with the invariance
and post conditions that we have been
looking for
as you probably heard earlier in the
talks within this
within the seminar there are probably a
lot of different ways
to solve this particular synthesis
problem
so in the interest of time i'm not going
to go through details here
but the ones that we have used so far
are basically different variants
of the stitches algorithm
now there are many different tricks that
we actually play in terms of making this
process efficient for example we try to
solve
incrementally in a sense that we try to
initially give
a simple expression grammar and then see
if the synthesizer already returns a
result
and if so our job is done otherwise we
try to expand the grammar by adding
more expressive rules into the grammar
so that it will consider
more expressive expressions and we also
try to use a
two-stage verification algorithm in our
synthesis process
where we first try to synthesize within
a bounded domain for example
limiting all integer variables to be of
size up to
10 for example and then we see if we can
already come up with invariance and post
conditions
and if we already saw if we already can
solve that problem
then we try to formally validate any
such post conditions
using a theorem prover for full-blown
verification
so there we have it so in our in our
in our previous line of work we have
been using this approach
where we first designed a high-level
specification language
where we can easily syntax
compile into the target framework that
we are trying to leverage
and then we are using inductive program
synthesis to help us
solve this inference process that
translates
from the input code into this high level
specification code
we claim that this is kind of best of
both worlds because
if you think about syntax driven
compilation it is basically dictated
by the number of constructs that we have
in the source
language in this case this high level
spec
because we basically need to write at
least one rule
for every construct in the source
language in order to translate into
something that is executable so
that is why translating from a high
level language with very few constructs
is actually much better than direct
translation from the source language
like java which has tons of different
types of constructs
on the other hand the complexity of
program synthesis
is dictated by the target language as
the target language
determines the size of the search space
that the synthesizer needs to consider
so it will be a bad idea if we search
directly
in the target language itself
but by first designing a high level
specification language
we actually capture the best of both
worlds by enabling the synthesis to
proceed really
efficiently and coupling that with a
very simple
pattern based syntax driven compilation
step
we call this combined approach verified
lifting
it is lifting in the sense that we are
converting
or inferring a high level specification
from the input source code as you know
this basically goes
against typical program compilation
because rather than going
from a high level to a low level
representation
we're actually reverting it by first
taking in the input source code
and trying to lift it up to a higher
level
representation and it is also called
verified
because anything that comes out from a
compiler is guaranteed to be
sound because we actually run through
all uh
found post condition through a theorem
prover
to make sure that it is actually valid
and semantically preserving
so for the rest of this talk let me
illustrate verified lifting
using one of the compilers that we have
built earlier called
casper and casper is exactly trying to
solve this problem i was referring to
earlier
in terms of compiling sequential java
program to map reduce
the casper 2 chain works in the
following way
so we take input source code with
written in sequential java
and then we have a very simple code
fragment identifier
all it does is it basically tries to
extract out pieces of code
that may be amenable to translate into
mapreduce and for each of these
identified code fragments
we then try to go through this synthesis
process
where we try to lift it to a high level
representation
represented using the language
constructs i alluded to earlier
and if all goes well then it goes
through the subsequent code generation
step
where we then actually generate
executable code
and we stitch that back into the input
application and then
we now have this input program now
rewritten
using spark
for evaluation purposes we collected a
bunch of benchmarks from
different type different domains to try
to validate
our casper compiler and these benchmarks
comes from
classical mapreduce problems that you
can imagine such as word count
and other kinds of mapreduce problems
and then to data analytical tasks
arithmetic statistical and even image
processing operations
so our evaluation shows that we are
actually able to translate
quite a bit of them acro around the
benchmarks that we put in
around 80 and there are a bunch of cases
where we
failed to translate some of the reasons
include the input program uses some
library methods that we
are that we are unfamiliar with so since
we don't understand the semantics of
what goes on inside those library calls
we are unable to translate
the corresponding input code some of
them was due to the limitation of the
grammar that we actually provide
so for example it might actually in in
it might actually involve a multi-map
reduce
stage and then we only limit it to two
stages for example
so therefore we're not able to translate
in those cases and then a bunch of them
were just due to
the synthesizer timing out without
returning anything
so i would basically also say that
in the in recent years we have seen a
lot of new advances
in program synthesis and some of them
you've probably already heard of
uh within this seminar so we expect this
synthesis
timing out step to be becoming less and
less of a problem
going onwards but now let's also take a
look
at the translated translated code i mean
after all we are trying to
be more efficient in terms of the
execution of the input program
so are we able to actually achieve that
so here i have highlighted a bunch of
sample benchmarks from the benchmark
suites that we
collected so these three bars here
correspond to
the translation performed by the mode
compiler
which is this syntax driven compilation
tool
that i referred to earlier in the
beginning of the talk
and in here the y-axis shows the amount
of speed up
as compared to the sequential java
implementation
from the beginning the green bars here
show the performance of the translator
code
that is generated by casper and as you
can see here
the mean speed up across the benchmarks
is around 20x
compared to the original sequential code
and we're able to translate
all the benchmarks that mode was able to
translate and on the other hand
since mode is not open source
and we're not able to get a copy of it
so therefore we're unable to evaluate it
across the other benchmarks that we're
able to collect
now however our evaluation also includes
a
human-based evaluation step in this case
we actually hired expert
spark programmers on a
on the on the online platform
and we try to we basically ask them to
manually translate all these benchmarks
by hand
and we also compare the performance of
those translated benchmarks
compared to the ones that spark what
sorry casper was able to come up with
so as you can see here our
implementation is actually quite
competitive
even against human experts you might
note that in one of the benchmarks here
3d histogram the human manual translated
implementation turns out to be much
faster than what
casper was able to find and the reason
for that was because
our expert programmer was able to
uh was was actually knowledgeable of
part of the spark api that does exactly
a 3d histogram computation versus
in our case for casper with an unaware
of that particular api
so it basically tries to translate that
into a multi-stage
map reduce and therefore turns out to be
slower than using the specialized
benchmark that the human is able to
uh is know as knowledgeable of
now you might say okay that's so far so
good but what about the time that it
actually takes
to do this compilation using casper
well so it takes on average around six
minutes to actually do the compilation
step
with the median being only two minutes
you might say well this is actually
quite a bit slower than something that
you might be able to get from
something like java c or any kind of
compiler that you might be familiar with
so i would claim that that is perhaps
the wrong measure
here because in this case we shouldn't
be measuring against those syntax driven
compilers
we should really be measuring against
the time that it takes to hire these
experts
and doing this completely manually for
instance
it literally took us weeks to do so so
you can imagine if you're working in a
company
and you have all these benchmarks that
you are trying to translate
then then the time that it takes to hire
these people and then bring that up to
speed
is perhaps not of that being very
competitive as
compared to the time that it takes for a
synthesis-based
approach to do so
so as a recap this is the verified
lifting tool chain that we have been
developing
over the past few years and this is
basically the general framework that we
have
for for doing code translation and in
addition to the
sequential java to spark compiler that
we have built earlier
we have actually also applied this
paradigm
to translate code from different types
of domains
for instance earlier we have implemented
another compiler called
dexter that takes c plus code and would
translate into
a domain specific language called halide
for image processing stencil computation
we have also used this approach to build
another compiler that takes sequential
java programs
that uses object relational mapping
libraries
like django and we basically translate
these java programs into
sql queries
and the advantage of doing that is now
we're able to leverage the
optimizers that relational databases
come with
and we're able to get quite a bit quite
a bit of speed up as a result of doing
that
and we have also used the same paradigm
to build
a domain-specific compiler that takes c
code
and compile it down to a programmable
switch
produced by this company earlier in the
down in the valley so i want to say that
like you know
we're basically just enabling all these
different codes and programs by using
our techniques
to leverage these different backends the
speed up that we get
is actually all due to the actual
back-end implementation itself
for example like the implementation of
spark so and so forth
our technique is basically the enabler
that allows these
existing programs to leverage these
frameworks easily
without building another syntax driven
compiler
so after all these different um
different lines of work that were
pursued earlier
we got a lot of requests by asking us to
translate from a new source language
into yet another target language
so now we are trying to abstract this
whole thing out into something called
metallift so it's basically a tool chain
that we are trying to build that would
enable other people
to build their own verified lifting
based
compiler 2 chain the way that it works
is
our framework is going to ask the user
to provide us
with a bunch of code fragments that
they're interested in
translating so this can be done
programmatically for instance by
identifying all
loopy programs or all specific programs
that iterate over
list or arrays so and so forth
and then we also ask the user to also
provide us with a specification language
uh of so this will be the high level
spec language that we have designed
earlier
and finally how to generate code from
this high level spec
into the actual executable target
platform
i encourage you to go visit this website
if you're interested
and we are actually an active
development of this
um of this framework and some of the
some of the compilers that we have built
earlier for example the
translation to halac one has already
been deployed at adobe
and some in fact some of the generated
code using the dexter compiler
is now shipping with adobe photoshop
so in this short talk i have introduced
you
to this new line of work that we have
been building upon that uses program
synthesis
to do code to build code translators
specifically
in this talk i have illustrated our
technique
using the casper compiler which
basically translates from sequential
java programs
into mapreduce and spark and metalift
is the framework that we are currently
building that hopefully will enable
other users
to leverage our technique without being
a synthesis expert
and with that thank you very much for
listening and i'd love to hear your
questions if you have any of them
thank you very much